[Música]
Boa noite, meus amigos, minhas amigas.
Boa noite, Alice Vogel, Alexandre
Galzisk, Miriam.
É um prazer ter com vocês aqui hoje. Por
favor, vão me falando se o áudio tá
legal, se vocês me escutam
bem, paraa gente poder dar
prosseguimento. Temos várias perguntas
aqui para responder
hoje. Tô com documento aqui
separado, então tô aguardando o feedback
paraa gente poder dar
seguimento. O som está bom? Alexandre
respondeu, então acho que eu posso
continuar aqui, mas era bom que pelo
menos mais uma pessoa
pudesse me dar o feedback.
Mas vamos
lá. Ah, deixa eu apresentar para
vocês. Bem, acho que tá bem visível
aqui. Primeira pergunta do Fernando.
Doutor, em um vídeo sobre exames de
sangue foi citado que o valor ideal de
RDW, o que que é o RDW?
é um parâmetro que mede o quanto que as
emácias têm um tamanho uniforme, tá?
Então, quanto maior esse número aqui,
maior é a diferença de tamanho entre as
emácias. E que valores acima desse
número indicariam o envelhecimento
acelerado com menor longevidade?
Aí ele colocou um link de um vídeo, mas
eu não consegui abrir esse vídeo, deu um
erro para mim aqui. No vídeo é citado
que para normalizar o RDW pode ser
utilizado B6, B9, B12, trimitlicina,
ômega3, ácido alfalipóico. Sim, seriam
boas alternativas. Sendo assim,
pergunto, o senhor, o senhor concorda
com o estudo apresentado? Não vi o
estudo apresentado porque o link para
mim não abriu. Onde o RDW inferior a
12,6 é um sinalizador? Isso daí é uma
informação que a primeira vez que eu
escutei isso foi quando eu fiz a
pós-graduação do Tolai Ribeiro. E eu
confesso a vocês que eu não investiguei
profundamente esse tema na
época. Se mesmo com a ingestão dos
suplementos recomendados RDW não
normalizar, o que que eu
recomendaria? Esse RDW, ele é
tradicionalmente utilizado para avaliar
anemias.
Então tem estudos recentes que acho que
foi o L Ribeiro mencionou na minha posse
e talvez foi o mencionado no vídeo. Eles
associaram níveis elevados RDW a maior
risco de doenças crônicas e maior risco
de envelhecimento
precoce. Então são estudos populacionais
que mostram que pessoas que tm o RDW
menor tem maior longevidade e menos
problemas.
cardiovasculares. E o intervalo padrão
de referência do laboratório é de 11,6 a
14,6.
Esses suplementos que você comentou
seriam um bom começo para ajudar no RDW,
mas não de uma maneira direta, mas sim
melhorando a saúde geral das pessoas que
têm deficiência desses nutrientes. A
trimetioglicina, por sua vez, ela tem
efeito antioxidante e ela aumenta a
gluta porque é um
dos precursores da gluta além de ser um
agente ventilador. Então sim, sem dúvida
ômega-3 também, como agente
antiinflamatório, isso seria uma boa um
bom ponto de entrada para melhorar o
RDW, né? Mas tem outras situações que
podem mudar o RDW. É o caso de esbiose
intestinal, ó, que vai prejudicar
absorção de nutrientes, estresse
oxidativo, doenças autoimunes, né?
Qualquer doença crônica pode metal o
RDW. Então, teria que fazer uma
avaliação completa de exames, né?
avaliando ferro, ferritina,
homocisteína, proteína ser
reativa, tentar analisar talvez o
microbioma intestinal com exames
específicos. E aí respondendo a tua
pergunta, além das vitaminas, eu
recomendaria usar antifamatórios
naturais, como curcumina, como
quercetina, como
fizetina, né? Tem vários aí que podem
ajudar. dá suporte ao fígado com cardano
ou siarina ou nac, né, junto com a
trimetil glicina para aumentar a
gluta se a pessoa tiver pré-diabetes ou
diabetes, usar berberina, usar o
picolinato e cromo, usar vanádio, usar
várias coisas aí para reduzir essa
questão e
também a carnosina para reduzir a
glicação. agentes antiinflamatórios, de
modo geral,
antioxidantes seriam
interessantes. Eh, estratégias aí de
estilo de vida, como otimização do
sono, meditação pro estresse, né, téc
meditação, téc relaxamento, exercícios
moderados e buscar doença de base que tá
causando essa alteração do RDW e
tratá-la diretamente, tá? Então, se for
diabetes, diabetes, se for pressão alta,
pressão alta. Se for doença autoimune,
tratar doença autoimune. Se for
desbiose, tratar desbiose e por aí vai,
tá? Então não dá para chegar a
conclusões
muito precisas só com o RDW. É só um um
marcador aí de alerta, mas tem que ser
visto o contexto clínico amplo. Beleza?
Próxima
pergunta da Estela Mares. Quando tomamos
o azul de metileno, necessariamente
vamos urinar
azul? Geralmente sim, mas depende da
dose, tá? Eu quando tomo o azul de
metilân, eu sempre
urino esverdeado ou azul, a não ser que
eu esteja muito muito hidratado, aí a
urina não fica colorida. Mas a dose que
eu tomo é 30, 40 mg. Se a dose for menor
do que essa em algumas pessoas, pode ser
que a urina não fique
colorida, tá? Então, primeiro fator é
dose. Quanto maior a dose, maior a
chance.
Quanto menos hidratada a pessoa vai est,
mais vai estar colorida a urina, né, por
pela
concentração. Se for endovenoso, né,
pela veia, vai ser muito mais visível a
coloração para uma dose menor, né,
porque endovenoso vai ter mais
biodisponibilidade, vai depender do
metabolismo
individual e não é um problema, tá? O
fato de tá colorando a urina azul ou
verde não quer dizer nada de
problemático, tá? É inofensivo esse
efeito, OK? E geralmente quando eu paro
de tomar azul de metileno demora de 24 a
48 horas paraa
urina clarear. Geralmente um pouquinho
mais de 24
horas. Tá bom. Não sei se você tá ao
vivo. Eu não te vi,
Stela, eu acho que
não. OK, temos mais um feedback de som
do Antônio Renato dizendo que tá
legal. Vamos pra próxima pergunta. Qual
é a diferença de nutrientes entre o
claro e missor escuro? Que que torna
claro? Que que torna
escuro? Então, entre um e o outro tem
diferenças nutricionais.
O miss claro, que no japonês é o xirô
missu, ele vai ter mais arroz na
composição, ele tem menos soja, ele tem
um sabor mais suave, adocicado, ele
possui um valor nutricional mais leve,
digamos assim, menor devido a menos
fermentação, que é uma fermentação de
menos semanas, tá? Poucas semanas.
O misso escluro, que é o acamissô, ele
tem maior concentração de soja, ele tem
um sabor mais acentuado, mais salgado,
ele tem mais nutrientes devido à
fermentação prolongada. A fermentação aí
equivalente a um vinho, né? pode durar
mais de 3 anos, ele tem um perfil
nutricional mais intenso. Então, se você
puder escolher e não tiver preferência
de sabor, o mior escuro é melhor. O que
determina a diferença de coloração é
basicamente os ingredientes. Quanto mais
arroz tiver, menos escuro ele vai ser.
Quanto mais soja tiver, mais escuro vai
ser. E também o tempo de fermentação.
Quanto maior o tempo de fermentação,
mais escuro fica a pasta do missô, OK?
Então o Missor Claro vai ser com certeza
mais barato, porque tem mais arroz e tem
menor duração de
fermentação. Então o que que faz o
missor fomentar? Um fungo chamado
aspergilus orizai, tá? Conhecido no
japonês como coj.
Alguns missoros podem levar cevada, isso
influencia na coloração
final e a proporção entre os
ingredientes, como eu disse, afeta
diretamente a cor do produto, OK? Então,
resumindo, quanto mais soja e mais tempo
de fermentação, mais escuro vai ser e
melhor vai ser também porque vai ter
mais
nutrientes por conta da soja e
fermentada, né, que é o ponto aí
principal do missor. Beleza? Então, se
puder escolher, escolha o missor
escuro. Próxima
pergunta. O aquecimento do missor usado
como tempero prejudica os benefícios
dele como
fermentado? Sim, quanto mais você
aquecer o missor, mais você vai perder
em termos de probióticos, porque são
bactérias, né? Elas são sensíveis a
calor, temperaturas acima de 46º vai
matar essas bactérias ou reduzir elas de
maneira
significativa. E quando o missor é
adicionado a líquidos ferventes que
excedem essa temperatura de
46º, os microrganismos vão morrer, ok?
Então, para maximizar os benefícios à
saúde, enquanto ainda você desfruta do
sabor, procure adicionar o missor
somente após o cozimento, depois que o
prato esfriar, né, para você não matar
as bactérias. Então, a temperatura do
prato deve est eh abaixo aí de 70º para
você adicionar o missor, entre 50 a 70.
E também você pode fazer o seguinte,
você pode criar uma pasta de
miss e misturando a pasta com uma
pequena quantidade de água morna e uma
tigela separada até ficar homogêneo.
Depois adiciona a mistura ao prato
depois de remover do fogo direto. OK?
Então o segredo é você adicionar depois
do preparo do alimento e temperaturas
mais
baixas para você não esse missor não
perder as
características. Então pra sopa de
missor, prepare o caldo, como de
costume, retire do fogo, assim que
atingir uma fervura leve, crie uma pasta
de missor numa tigela separada, como eu
expliquei, e depois misture de volta na
sopa morna, ok? Quais são os benefícios
do Missô? Por ser um agente fermentado
cheio de probióticos, vai ter várias
vitaminas essenciais, o complexo B, K2,
manganês, cobre, zinco, proteína, fibra.
Tem antioxidantes que vão ajudar a
prevenir o dano celular e reduzir
doenças. vai dar suporte ao coração, vai
ajudar a equilibrar as gorduras do
sangue, ajudar a equilibrar a pressão
arterial, pode proteger contra certos
tipos de câncer e dar suporte à saúde
digestória através da melhoria de
absorção de nutrientes, OK? e utilize,
se for possível, missor não
posterizado e com esses cuidados de não
aumentar de mais temperatura, como eu
comentei. Marilda, Dr. Roberto Zebal
sugere uma mistura em partes iguais de
soro fisiológico e povidine para lavar
as vias
aéreas. Para esse mesmo
fim, poderia se substituir pelo
Povidini.
Se sim, em qual
proporção? Bem, eh, eu dei uma olhada
nesse assunto porque realmente eu não
conhecia isso e onde eu
pesquisei dizia que usar lugol para
lavagem nasal
recomendado. Eu acho que ela é
potencialmente irritativa
mesmo. A fonte que eu consultei
recomendou usar soro fisiológico, né?
que é o que eu recomendo também,
fisiológico, você pode usar também
bicarbonato sódio, pode usar também água
oxigenada diluída,
OK? Onde eu consultei nem o povidini,
nem o Lugol, era recomendado, mas
sinceramente eu nunca vi esse assunto
dessa forma. não conheço esse material
do Zebalo sobre esse
assunto, então teria que ver as
argumentações dele, mas eu acho que pelo
que eu conheço Povidini Logol seria
muito irritativo para
nariz, mas se for muito diluído, talvez
seja uma boa, tá? Mas sinceramente eu
não vejo por usar ovidini se você pode
usar água oxigenada ou usar bicarbonato.
Eu não sei muito por que seria uma
vantagem usar. Tá, mas se você tiver o
material do Zebalos, eu gostaria de dar
uma olhada, tá? Mas teoricamente, se
você Vamos considerar aqui que onde eu
li tá errado, tá? Que poderia usar o
POVID nas vias
aéreas. Ah, você poderia usar realmente
o Lugol no lugar porque é muito
parecido, tá? Só que eu realmente eu não
tenho certeza da concentração porque eu
não li sobre esse assunto, não achei
fontes falando bem disso daí, tá? também
foi uma piscina
rápida, mas pensando aqui do que eu
conheço povinol, eu acho que a chance de
irritar as vias aéreas é bem grande e
não vejo uma razão boa para não usar
soro fisiológico com bicarbonato,
tá?
Mas estou aberto também, não sou uma
autoridade nesse assunto, tá?
Pergunta do Thiago. Na sua opinião, para
erne de atos seria a cirurgia a única
opção ou teria algo dentro da medicina
natural? Aí a resposta é depende. Se for
uma herne de deslizamento grande tem que
operar
sim. Consigo controlar alguns sintomas
com estilo de vida? Sim, consegue, mas
não sei se os distúrbios
gastrointestinais que ainda tenho são
devido a isso ou não, pois o gastro diz
que se eu não fizesse cirurgia, mesmo
com alimentação saudável, teria
problemas. Olha aí que eu falei, é
difícil opinar a
distância. O que eu te diria é o
seguinte, é uma hérneia grande, é melhor
operar. É uma hérneia pequena, não
opere. Seria a resposta rápida, tá?
O que que você pode fazer dentro do
estilo de vida caso a sua hérne de atos
não seja tão grande assim, né? Você já
falou que já tá controlando sintomas.
Primeiro é comer devagar, mastigar bem o
alimento, não tomar líquido junto com as
refeições, evitar refeições pesadas ou
comer demais, controlar o peso, porque
quanto mais pesado, mais
refluxo, não é o seu caso, mas seria
parar de fumar também, reduzir o consumo
de álcool, bebida gaseificada e também
evitar deitar-se logo depois de comer, 3
horas de intervalo entre comer à noite e
deitar e dormir com travesseiro ou
cabeceira da cama. cama elevado, tá?
Travesseiro elevado e cabeceiro da cama
elevado. Em termo de comida, consumir
fruta e vegetais ricos em fibras, optar
por grão
natural, proteínas eh também com de
qualidade, incluir alimentos com
probióticos e as plantas da fitoterapia
que você poderia estar utilizando.
Espinheira santa é bom, guaçatong é
bom e a cúrcuma sem a piperina é bom
também, tá? Tem um produto no mercado
que chama cubo, que é cúrcuma junto com
a bozuélia. São dois anti-inflamatórios
estão sendo utilizados para saúde
gastrointestinal.
Chá de camomilão boa, chá de erva doce,
chá de gengibre, chá de aloe vera, a
própria aloe vera na forma de suco, né,
ou de aloe vera em cápsula também bem
interessante.
Então é outra coisa que eu não comentei,
se você tiver esôfago de barret, que é
aquele esôfago que houve já uma
metaplasia escamosa, aí eu indicaria
para você cirurgia também, tá? Porque
isso é um sinal de gravidade. Então não
sei se o cirurgião comentou, se você tem
isófo de
barret, então esse é um critério
importante. OK? Muito boa sorte para
você. Pensa duas vezes,
mas verifica o grau da tua hérnia,
porque o cirurgão pode estar forçando a
barra para operar também, tá? Então, se
for uma hérneia pequena, não opere. Se
for uma hérnia grande com isofod, eu
recomendo que você faça a
cirurgia. Na minha academia colocaram
uma cama de luz vermelha. Qual sua
opinião sobre terapia de luz vermelha?
se vale a pena o
investimento. Mas aí eu não entendi.
Colocaram na academia e você quer
comprar e colocar em casa isso? Porque
investimento seria da academia, não
seria o seu,
né? Ou você, tá, talvez você esteja
dizendo que eles estão cobrando por fora
o uso da cama, né? Bem, luz vermelha,
luz infravermelha, é, é tudo isso é
muito interessante, tá? Realmente essa
essas luzes têm potencial terapêutico,
elas penetram a
pele, existe benefício à
saúde, tem pesquisa mostrando isso.
Então, quando você usa a luz vermelha na
pele, você pode melhorar a aparência, a
saúde da pele, porque estimula a
produção de colágeno, ajuda a manter a
elasticidade, reduzir o aparecimento de
linhas finas e
rugas, melhora o tom e a textura.
reduz a
pigmentação, ajuda com acne, reduz
cicatrizes, a terapia funciona
penetrando profundamente na pele e
promoveação celular e cicatrização.
Então, tem relatos e estudos mostrando
que a luz vermelha reduz dores crônicas,
reduz artrite, diminui inflamação em
áreas
afetadas, acelera a recuperação muscular
após exercícios, promove cicatrização de
feridas e melhora a circulação
sanguínea, entrega mais oxigênio e
nutriente aos
tecidos, estimula as mitocôndrias
também. Isso eu vi um estudo muito
interessante um uns meses ou anos atrás
mostrando que essa luz vermelha era
incorporada mesmo diretamente pela
mitocôndria. Então pode aumentar a
produção de ATP e energia celular,
ajudar as células a responder melhor a
danos.
OK? E a luz é muito segura. Efeitos
colaterais mínimos. Efeitos colaterais
são raros, pode ser coceira na pele,
acne temporária, sensibilidade, mas além
de ser raro, geralmente é
leve. Tem que usar um óculos de proteção
porque a exposição à luz vermelha pode
danificar a
retina e os resultados dependem de uso
consistente ao longo do
tempo. Eh, não sei quanto é que essa
academia tá cobrando, né?
Não sei se essa academia cobra por
sessão, se tem pacote, como é que é, mas
geralmente precisa de várias sessões,
tá? Duas a três vezes por semana por um
a 4
meses. Agora, se vale a pena o
investimento, vai depender do seu caso,
né? Se você já com a pele
ruim, talvez vha a pena.
Se tiver com artrite também, né, como eu
comentei, ou artrite ou ou pele ruim,
pode ser uma boa, né, para ajudar no
fotoenvelhecimento. Tem que ver quais
são suas necessidades, mas se tiver
fotoenvelhecimento ou ou artrite, vale a
pena. Sim. Tá.
Alguma recomendação para idoso que
retirou a próstata? Precisa suplementar
com alguma coisa ou tem algo mais que a
medina tradicional geralmente não
recomenda ou considera mais seria
importante? Bem, aí tem que saber que
cirurgia que é, né? se é a cirurgia
próstatectomia simples ou radical, que é
o do câncer,
tá? Mas eu acho que você tá perguntando
de recuperação de
cuidados tardios, né? que o
pós-operatório
imediato geralmente surgião ele
orienta. Bem, se você tá falando do
pós-operatório imediato, seria você
evitar esforços físicos durante o
primeiro mês após a cirurgia para evitar
também sangramento e a abrir a ferida,
repouso relativo nesses 30 dias.
hã, evitar de dirigir veículos também
nesse
período. A alimentação seria uma
alimentação saudável, né, cheio de
elementos antioxidantes, de fibras.
Em alguns casos é recomendado comer
alimentos laxativos se a pessoa tiver
prisão de ventre ou constipação para
evitar que tenha que fazer esforço
vacuatório e pode influenciar aí nos nas
nos pontos da
cirurgia. Aumentar a gestão de líquidos
seria importante para você clarear mais
urina e não deixar os coágolos se
formarem.
E também como é que você vai fazer para
se recuperar bem depois de uma cirurgia?
Comer bastante proteína, né? Porque vai
precisar de aminoácido para recuperação
cirúrgica, para
cicatrização e para preservar massa
muscular depois da cirurgia. A glutamina
seria interessante para dar suporte
intestinal e também sistema imune. O
colágeno também seria a mesma
situação, além de contribuir paraa saúde
ósse articular.
ômega-3 pela suação
anti-inflamatória e de suporte o sistema
nervoso, né, que também pode est
precisando de suporte nesse período. Ô3
também vai ajudar no sistema
imune. Em termos assim de suplementos
específicos, digamos assim, para,
digamos, seja um câncer e você quer
prevenir recidiva do câncer, licopen
seria uma boa, porque ele é um
antioxidante que em estudos é comprovado
que ele reduz o risco de câncer, tá?
Então, seria interessante usar o licopen
como suplemento ou consumir moro de
tomate. O selênio e iodo também tem ação
anticâncer, a vitamina D de dado e A2
também.
Tá? D2 não, D3 e K2, né? Esse seria
interessante também. E paraa recuperação
do da musculatura
pélvica, primeiro ano após a cirurgia,
você pode ter incontinência urinária, se
for aquela cirurgia mais estendida do
câncer, né? Aí você faz treinamento dos
musculaturas, desculpa, da dos músculos
da região pélvica para ajudar no
controle urinário. Você pode fazer uma
reabilitação do assoalho pélvico, pode
fazer biofeedback,
eletroestimulação para ajudar nisso
também pode fazer a
computa, entendeu? Então são essas as
medidas aí. Não sei se eu respondi a tua
pergunta, não sei se você tá ao vivo,
Thago. Eu acho que
não. Vamos pra próxima.
Blanderson, dicas para baixar o
dedímero. Minha mãe de 66 anos, tem
cardíaca, é estável, muito cansaço, a
fazer tarefa simples, passou mal dias
atrás, já estou por fora dando solução
de Sinatra. Boa ideia. Cardiologista deu
um pulo porque pedi fibrinogênio e
dimero. Fibrinogênio dentro de dois
quartis. Deve ser dos dos primeiros dois
quartis, né? que eu tô entendendo. E
dimero de
1200. É porque na verdade o dimero ele
aumenta com várias coisas, tá? Não é só
com trombo não,
tá? Ah, tomou astras, né? Astras, vamos
chamar assim para não atrapalhar o
vídeo. E dois corona, né? Orientei na
época, mas não teve
jeito, tá? Eh, você quer dicas para
baixar o dedímero? Bem, primeiro é o
seguinte, o dedim ele tem aumentado com
inflamação, com infecção, não é só com
trombo,
certo? Ela provavelmente tá tomando
algum tipo de antiagregante plaquetário
ou anticoagulante, certo? Não sei, você
não colocou
aqui. Solução de sinatra top. Faça isso
mesmo, que vai dar suporte ao músculo
cardíaco. Agora, eu tenho um paciente
aqui na clínica que passa comigo tem uns
três ou 4 anos e como ele fez
alcoolização, procedimento
invasivo, ele tinha hipertrofia
cardíaca e aí ele fez um procedimento de
alcoolização. O dedinho dele nunca caiu,
sem fica alto por causa dessa
alcoolização aí.
Então tem que ver caso a caso, tá? Então
de maneira grosseira, digamos
assim, eu faria o seguinte, era
natoquinase e piquenogenol, OK? 200 mg
de cada por
dia. Agora, em relação ao cansaço da sua
mãe, observa como é que vai ser a
resposta ao protocolo Sinatra aí, né? A
solução
Sinatra. Se não melhorar, aí vai ter que
reavaliar, né?
Tá? Então eu só queria que você ficasse
com isso na cabeça, que o dedimo, ele
não é um
marcador específico para trombo, tá?
Talvez seja por isso que o cardiologista
ficou
bravo,
porque eh ele deve ter
interpretado que você tava
entendendo que o dedímero era
necessariamente um trombo e não é.
Infelizmente ele não é específico assim,
tá? Agora, se ela tomou aí as
picadinhas, dá para ela a ivemmectina.
Além da, que eu já falei, né, do
toquinase e
pnogenol, dá para ela
ivemectina, dá para ela
probiótico, dá para ela nac, tá bom? E
pensa em dar também dente de leão,
porque ela deve estar com a proteína S
aumentada no sistema
dela. E se você tiver ao vivo, a gente
troca mais ideias sobre esse caso aí, tá
bom? Eu não vi você ao vivo, Anderson.
Ah, apareceu aqui. Tá, você tá aqui,
sim.
Tá. É que tem um bug no Streamyard. Eu
só consigo ver quem
está falando alguma coisa aqui no no
chat. Eu não consigo ver o pessoal que
tá ao
vivo porque a transmissão tá sendo
feita, né, pros apoiadores. Então, o
Streamyard ele não tem essa integração
boa quando é uma transmissão fechada.
Ele respondeu aqui, ó, Charelto 20 mg
por dia que ela tá
tomando, né? Então, tá tomando
anticoagulante, sim. Só o Charelto aí,
ele já dá uma segurada na fibrinogêno,
viu? E também no na no
dedímero, tá? Mas se você tiver mais
alguma dúvida, se não responde
totalmente sua pergunta, pode interagir
ao vivo aqui, tá,
Blanderson? Vamos pro próximo aqui, pá.
Pá, Dr. Alan, quais exames de urina e de
sangue para saber a saúde dos
índs? Esses são exames bem básicos, né?
É creatinina, urea no sangue, né? Os
eletrólitos, sódio, potássio,
cloreto. O marcador mais importante é
creatinina. Quando tá acima de 1,2 já
tem algum comprometimento na função
renal geralmente ou a pessoa tá
consumindo bastante proteína que pode
afetar também a creatinina, tá? Nem
sempre a suícia renal creatinina acima
de
1,2. Existe um cálculo que é feito que é
a taxa de filtração glomerular, que é
uma continha que o laboratório faz com a
creatinina e dá uma estimada da
eficiência dos insins na filtragem. Só
que isso aqui é impreciso, tá? Muitas
vezes tem que pedir a o clearance de
creatinina ou depuração de creatinina
endógena para poder chegar a uma
conclusão mais assertiva.
Então, já falei, ureia, creatinina,
sendo que a cretinina é mais precisa que
a ureia, mas mesmo assim a cretina
muitas vezes tá errada no sentido de tá
mostrando insência renal, porque a
pessoa tá consumindo muita proteína,
aumenta creatinina, a creatina é
suplemento, também pode aumentar a
creatinina sem danificar o rim. Isso
confundiu a cabeça de muita gente por
muito tempo. Tem um marcador mais
preciso que é a cistatina C, que eu peço
quando eu vejo caso de cretinas de 1.3
1.4, eu peço esse marcador cistatina
C. Isso é uma alternativa interessante
emos, tá? Ou pessoas com baixa massa
muscular. Você também pode est checando
os eletróles, como eu comentei, sódio,
potássio, cloreto, cálcio também,
magnésio. Isso também é importante
porque tem casos de fírenal que é muito
comum aumentar o potássio no
sangue. Então tem que ver essa questão
dos equilíbrios dos
eletrólitos. Exame de urina seria o
sumário de urina ou eas, né? Ou urina
tipo um. Tem esses três nomes, né? Urina
tipo um. é a s o sumário de
urina seria um exame básico para ver
função renal também que vê se tem
proteína, se tem açúcar na urina, se tem
células
vermelhas. A relação alumina creatinina
na urina. Então você pode ver também
essa relação e a própria presença de
albumina ou de proteína na urina, que é
proteinúria ou aluminúria na urina.
Quanto mais proteína tiver na urina ou
albumina, é sinal de lesão
renal. O clínico creatinina já comentei,
tá? Então são esses exames. Ureia,
creatinina, cistatina C, clínic
creatinina, os eletrólitos, sódio,
potássio,
cloreto, cálcio,
magnésio, exame de urina tipo um e
proteinúria e abuminúria na urina. e a
relação também da proteína em 24 horas
com, desculpa, a relação entre albumina
e creatinina na urina também, tá? Então
é, são esses
exames. Eh, se uma pessoa estiver com
problemas nos rins, ela pode consumir
água com limão
normalmente? Geralmente sim, tá?
Geralmente sim. Se for uma espereal
leve, não tem problemas maiores,
ok? O citrato, né, o ácido cítrico que
vira citrato no limão pode ajudar a
prevenir a formação de pedras. Isso é
interessante para quem tem problema no
rim.
Á, com limão pode contribuir paraa
hidratação. Se a pessoa tiver uma renal
muito acentuada, aí vai ter que
conversar com o médico e ver caso a
caso, OK? Mas para 95% das pessoas seria
tranquilo tomar água com limão com
essência renal leve, moderada, ok?
Quem tem problema nos rins pode fazer
dieta cetogênica normalmente. Quais
pessoas têm
restrições? A maior restrição da dieta
cetogênica bem feita, tá? Lembrando aqui
que eu nunca vou falar da dieta
cetogênica mal feita. Qual que é a bem
feita? Tem vegetais, tem vegetais
coloridos, tem fibra, tem hidratação,
não tem excesso de proteína, tá? Porque
as pessoas confundem dieta cetogênica
com a dieta de atquins ou dieta
hiperproteica, não é? E dieta
hiperproteica, a dieta cetogênica. E
você sabem que tem um preconceito muito
grande por aí com a dieta cetogênica e
na maioria das fontes que vocês for
consultar vai dizer que não é
recomendada para pessoas com problemas
renais.
E existe essa história que vai
sobrecarregar os rins, né? Mas eu acho
que o pessoal confunde muito a
diacetogênica com a de ATP proteica que
poderia sobrecarregar os
rins. Porém, temos estudos interessantes
com a doença renal
policística, que é um ensaio clínico
randomizado controlado, que mostrou que
a dieta acetogênica pode ser benéfica
para pacientes com essa condição,
ajudando a controlar o crescimento dos
cistos e até melhorando a função renal.
Então isso é meio contraditório, né?
Como é que essa dieta é ruim pro rim se
o sujeito que tem dessa renal
policística é beneficiado, né? Não faz
muito sentido,
né? Então, pelo menos nessa questão da
doença renal policística, tem estudo já
mostrando que a dieta
cetogênica é uma boa. Quais seriam os
grupos que não deveriam utilizar a dieta
etogênica? Eu acho que principalmente
pessoas magras demais, que têm massa
muscular ruim, esse pessoal eu não
recomendaria. Eu acho que deveria
primeiro ganhar massa muscular antes de
fazer uma dieta
citogênica. Não é o caso, por exemplo,
dos
obesos. Eh, aí teria que fazer a
cetogênica. Sim. Agora, a pessoa que é
muito magra e meio caquética, eu não
recomendaria a cetogênica. Eu primeiro
faria uma
dieta com aumento de proteína e cortando
um carboidrato refinado, deixando os
carboidratos
complexos. Algumas pessoas que tm
insência hepática descontrolada também
não deveriam fazer o uso da dieta
cetogênica.
Pessoas que têm problemas na vesícula
biliar deveriam resolver primeiro o
problema antes de adotar a dieta
citogênica, porque o aumento de consumo
de gordura poderia desestabilizar esse
problema da
vesícula. Pessoas que têm digestão ruim
de gordura ter que resolver primeiro
problema antes de fazer a
cetogênica. Seria basicamente esse
grupo, tá? esses grupos que eu
comentei, algumas pessoas que fazem
dieta cetogênica sem orientação podem
ter pedra nos
rins, tá? Então isso é um ponto que tem
que tomar cuidado, certo? E tem aquela
questão da ketoflu, né? Aquele passarmal
do começo da dieta cetogênica que muitas
pessoas têm. que acontece por
deficiência de hidratação e deficiência
de minerais, que é resolvível se a
pessoa toma mais água e come abacate,
mas muitas vezes ela não faz isso, aí
passa mal no começo, tendo dor de
cabeça, náusea, irritabilidade,
ã, fadiga, né? Então isso tudo pode ser
prevenível, não é necessariamente tem
que ter a catetoflu para quem faz a
dieta cetogênica.
Então, perguntas respondidas. Deixa eu
ver se eu tenho gente ao vivo com
pergunta. O senhor
chegou a olhar aquela questão do io de
iodo de algas por ser orgânico e não ser
o mais
ideal e o inorgânico ser mais adequado?
Não, não olhei não, Fernando. É quando é
assim, gente, coloca a pergunta para mim
no questionário,
tá? Porque eu respondi essa pergunta
numa live anterior, não
foi? Você me mandou a fonte da de onde
você viu
isso, porque eu acho que isso é muito
mais opinativo do que real mesmo, tá?
O Blanderson disse que eu respondi bem.
Obrigado.
Ótimo. Já tá usando vemctina,
Blanderson. Porque pode ser que também
ele tenha medo de usar, né? Por causa
daquela história lá do da lesão hepática
que eu nunca
vi. Melhores probióticos? Não sei,
Blanderson. Eu geralmente eh
recomendaria um pool de probióticos com
lactobacilos e bifobactérium, mas eu não
eu não sei se existe já uma algum estudo
falando que o probiótico A melhor que o
B.
Tá, doutor, é possível utilizar
progesterona para impedir a menstruação?
Progesterona não. Progestina sim, tá?
Você poderia usar uma gestrinona, por
exemplo, para impedir a menstruação por
10 meses, que é uma progestina. Tem
outras também, né? Né? Não é só
progestina, mas é o que eu conheço mais
e tem mais experiência. E dar um
intervalo de 2 meses para fechar um
ano não seria não. Mas nesse caso seria
sim o método contraceptivo, né? Se você
usar gestrinone em altas doses para
cortar a menstruação, vai acabar sendo
método
contraceptivo, tá? Mas é possível sim,
mas não é progesterona base. É, eu não
recomendo progesterona base ou
bioidêntica para isso. Eu recomendo que
utilize
progestina. Objetivo seria evitar o uso.
Nesse caso, não teria como evitar o uso
não, viu? para cortar
menstruação. Projetora não é a melhor
coisa não. Não vai ser eficiente para
isso que você quer não.
Ã, coloquei a fonte no grupo semana
passada. Gente, eh, eu peço para vocês
não colocarem coisa necessariamente no
grupo. O grupo é para vocês, não é para
mim, tá? Eu não me coloco, digamos
assim, com essa obrigação de ficar
olhando as
mensagens do grupo, porque realmente a
minha rotina hoje em dia tá muito
puxada, porque eu tô com projetos
paralelos, eu
[Música]
tô pouquíssimas horas de lazer, tá?
Então eu peço essa, por gentileza, para
vocês a compreensão que eu não vou ficar
monitorando o grupo. De vez em quando eu
pego uma coisa aqui, outra ali, tá?
Mas o grupo é para vocês, não é para mim
para eu ficar monitorando as perguntas.
Por isso que a gente tem esse encontro
semanal, senão não precisaria, né? Era
só ficar lá olhando as perguntas que
você soltassem lá
no Peço desculpas, tá, Fernando, acho
que não é isso que você queria escutar,
mas
eh coloca a fonte agora
aqui. Aí eu vou aí eu te eu te prometo
que eu vejo para você, tá bom? Eu vou
deixar na minha agenda para não
esquecer.
H colo nova pergunta com as fontes no
formulário. Pode ser, mas se quiser
mandar aqui, ó, a nas mensagens, eu já
vou copiar e colar e vou ver antes,
tá? Não, mas aqui, Vanders, a ideia
seria o uso contínuo da invemectina,
viu? Eu sei que dá medo, mas seria e
essa a situação,
tá? Tá. Deixa eu fazer o seguinte, eu
vou aproveitar aqui na live, eu vou
entrar no grupo agora e eu vou tentar
localizar essa esse link que você mandou
lá, tá,
Fernando? Eu já vou deixar separado
isso. Deixa eu Ah, não, já fechei aqui.
Tem que abrir aqui. Pera aí. Web. Tá.
Deixa eu entrar
aqui no
grupo, tentar achar a sua. Aliás, se
você tiver, se você não se incomodar,
você pode colar de novo a o link para
não ficar caçando muito aqui. Deixa eu
ver se eu consigo achar aqui.
Coloquei o seu nome Blanderson agora.
Não, não é Blanderson. Tô, tô olhando
errado. É, é Casteliano.
Desculpa. Ver se eu acho
aqui. Aqui, ó, teve uma mensagem dia 11
de março. Hashimoto Yodo orgânico. Eu
achei.
Achei. Ah, obrigado. Eu vou, já, já
achei aqui. Copiar endereço no link.
Vou ver que conversa é essa de odio
orgânico que é ruim aqui.
Tá um
aqui. Vou ver os argumentos que ele
usa. Tá, tô com as com as duas guias
aqui. Deixa eu adicionar os
favoritos. Não, pera aí. Acho melhor
primeiro entrar, né?
Entrei,
entrei.
Pronto, já achei aqui.
Ã, cadê? Deixa eu colocar aqui nos
favoritos.
Pronto. Barra de favoritos. Medicina,
nutrição.
Pronto. Medicina
Pronto. Aí eu vou ver depois da live. Eu
vou ver e a gente conversa na próxima.
Ah, tem uma outra coisa que
eu preciso. Ah, são cortes, né? É
verdade. São vídeos bem curtinhos.
Seria melhor
eu, porque eu li recentemente sobre isso
daí, viu? Não vi nenhuma coisa falando
contra iodo orgânico, não. O que o que
eu li falando da quantidade do iodo
kelp. Se você fosse ingerir do kelp, da
alga
kelp, seria questão de você tomar
cuidado com a quantidade, né, para não
ser
excessiva. Agora, não é o
necessariamente o kelp que é ruim, mas é
porque ele tem mais concentração de iodo
e aí você teria que tá tomando cuidado
com a quantidade. E aí essa essa fonte
que eu li falava de usar água marrom no
lugar por conta da que tem menos
concentração de iodo. Agora demonizar o
iodo orgânico por causa
disso, eu já não concordo, cara. Nunca
tive problema com iodo orgânico,
não. Tá sabendo
usar, mas eu vou ver aí. É porque às
vezes que acontece, você tem os
cardiols, desculpem, ele ele acho que
ele é endocrinologista,
né? O camarada ele quer falar diferente
do resto para para aparecer, entendeu?
Para dizer que ele sabe mais.
E aí ele pega uma nota de rodapé de um
livro e fala daquilo como se fosse troço
mais importante do mundo para dizer que
ele é o dono da autoridade do do
assunto. Eu acho que pode ser isso, tá?
Sem querer fazer julgamento de valor aí
do Alexandre, que eu mal conheço ele. Eu
sei que ele é um cara
famoso.
Eh, esse pessoal que imita o baracá já
fico com um pé atrás, viu?
Esse cara, esse, eu chamo esse pessoal
de filhote de baracá, eles imitam o
baracá. Por que que eu falo isso? O cara
usa terna impecável, barbinha
alabaracá, cabelinho alabaracá, parece
que é filho do baracá, né?
Entendeu? Eu já já fico meio desconfiado
quando é assim, sabe? Eh, esse pessoal
aí que imita o Baracá, eu não gosto isso
não. Eh, acho isso aí uma falta de
personalidade do caramba, entendeu? Mas
não quer dizer nada. Ele, cara, esse
cara é famoso, sim. Ele é famoso. Até
onde eu sei, ele é bom, tá? Pode ser que
ele tá inventando história aí só para
poder aparecer, não sei. Vou dar uma
olhada nisso aí, tá? Mas a resposta
rápida é o seguinte, o problema não é
que é o iodo é orgânico que vai ser
tóxico, é a quantidade. É mesmo quando
logol, o logol é tóxico, depende. Tem
gente que toma logol a vida inteira, não
dá nada. Eu parei de recomendar o logol
justamente porque a concentração é muito
alta. Se
a argumentação dele é porque o lugol é
inorgânico, só por causa disso que aí
ele recomenda lugol. Não sei se esse se
se é isso que ele recomenda. Eu acho que
o gol é muito mais perigoso do que iodo
orgânico, tá? Pelo que eu li meses
atrás, anos atrás, mas vamos ver se se
eu conseguir extrair alguma coisa de
mais específica. Você mandou dois vídeos
de um minuto, né? Eu vou ter que acho
que olhar outros materiais dele para
entender melhor o raciocínio, porque
duvido que um minuto ele vai explicar em
detalhes porque que ele não gosta de odo
orgânico, entendeu?
Sim, eu concordo,
Fernando. Eu concordo com esse
comentário seu aqui. Não dá para saber
se é para obter engajamento. Sim, muita
gente faz isso, tá? Então vocês fiquem
ligados. Tem gente que gosta de falar o
contrário de todo mundo, só para dizer
que ele é o fodão, que ele que manja das
dos paranauê, tá? Não necessariamente é
máfé, mas às vezes é um truque de
marketing para dizer que ele tem
autoridade, tá?
Tem que tomar cuidado com
isso. Você diz que não achou em outros
vídeos mais informações sobre
iodo. É, vou tentar
achar. Vou tentar achar. Vou ver se eu
não sei se ele tem canal no YouTube.
Deve ter, né? Tem sim. Ó, Dr. Alexandre
Duarte, o canal é dele. Vou tentar achar
que Fernando, tá? Mas assim, desculpa,
eu não fico muito preso no que o Dr. A
falou, Dr. B falou, Dr. C falou. Eu
gosto de ciência, tá, né? Então eu não
tenho nenhum problema aqui de mudar de
ideia, de falar para vocês: "Olha, li de
novo sobre o assunto X, descobri novas
informações, mudei de ideia, não tem
problema nenhum, não tô casado com
nenhuma das minhas convicções, tá?
Aliás, eu não tenho convicções, eu tenho
coisas que eu estudei e eu tento passar
para vocês as coisas mais relevantes e
sinceras da minha parte,
né? Agora tem gente que casa com aquele
negócio. O cara falou um negócio lá há
10 anos atrás, ele ele só porque ele
falou, ele é casado com aquele com
aquela opinião e não muda de ideia. Eu
não sou assim, mas também não vou mudar
a ideia do nada só porque o cara bonitão
lá falou, né? Ainda mais o cara que é o
clone do Baracá. Aí eu fico mais pé
atrás ainda, né? Tá
certo. Pergunta do Antônio
Renato. Você você colocou a pergunta no
questionário? É isso,
Antônio? Ah, tá aqui. Exame para saber
se tem um problema na
vesícula. É basicamente ultrassom de
abdômen superior, tá? Para ver sua
vesícula.
Se tiver alguma suspeita que você tem
cálculo no colédoco, né, ou algum
problema nas vias biliares entrepáticas,
pode ser necessário às vezes uma
ressonância de vias biliares, pode ser,
pode ser também necessário uma
colangopancreatografia retrógrado
endoscópica. Hoje cada vez é menos se
faz isso. Quando eu tava na rede de
cirurgia geral era um exame
relativamente frequente para pessoas que
tinham suspeita de pancreas biliar. Hoje
é mais usa mais ressonância do que
naquela época, tá? Mas é 95% das vezes é
ultrassom de abdômen superior que pega a
vesícula e alguns casos anjor
ressonância, desculpa, colâo ressonância
em alguns casos e outros casos mais
raros ainda essa PR que é a colango,
pancatro
colopreatrografia retrógrado
endoscópica. Respondi, Antônio, era essa
pergunta que você tava me cobrando.
Desculpa, eu não vi.
Eh, dieta carnívora. A propósito, o que
que eu falo a respeito do carnívora? Eu
tenho um vídeo, Blanders sobre dieta
carnívora, dois, na verdade, eh, eu acho
fiz uns 3 anos
atrás e eu falo que a dieta cannívora
bem feita, que é difícil para caramba
fazer a dieta canívora bem feita, é uma
ótima alternativa para doença autoimune,
tá? para pessoas que têm doença
autoimune. O problema é que 95% das
pessoas fazem errado essa dieta, tá?
Quando o pessoal fala dieta carnívora, a
pessoa fala de comer músculo, né? Bife,
comer frango, bife e peixe, né? Que é
músculo de desses animais. Aí o pessoal
não come vícera, não come fígado, não
come moela, não
come sarapatel, não come tim, não come
coração, não come. Eh, porque a dieta
carnívora em si tem que comer bastante
vícera, algumas bem exóticas, tá?
Então não é fácil, é bem mais difícil
fazer essa dieta do que fazer a
dieta vegana ou vegetariana.
Existe uma empresa que eu falei nessa
live, nesses foi uma live, um vídeo
gravado sobre essa empresa lá
de da Oceania, né,
de não é Austrália, é Nova Zelândia, uma
empresa Nova Zelândia que vende víceras
liofilizadas em cápsula para as pessoas
que estavam fazendo essa dieta aí, OK?
Então, é uma dieta de exceção, é uma
dieta para quem tem doença autoimune.
Pode ser uma boa para quem tem
eh algumas doenças autoimunes, pode ser
a única dieta que
resolve, mas é uma dieta muito difícil
de fazer, tá? Assiste meus vídeos lá no
canal sobre
isso. Até semana que vem, Antônio. Sim,
um abraço para você
também. Doutor, essa nova onda de
medicina metabólica, onde exigem exigem
consultas a cada 3 meses para ajustar os
protocolos, seria mais uma estratégia
para manter pacientes consultando?
É, é o seguinte, eh, tem muitos nomes aí
que, na verdade, se você for ver, é
praticamente a mesma coisa. Por exemplo,
existia a medicina, que ficou popular há
20 anos atrás, mas foi perseguida pelo
Conselho de Medicina. Aí muita gente
começou a evitar o
nomecular porque não era especialidade
reconhecida pelo
conselho. E depois o conselho reconheceu
como área de atuação, mas não como área
de atuação no sentido, você pode
registrar isso, mas seria uma
estratégias válidas, né? Então ficou
nesse limbo aí.
Aí depois vem a medicina
integrativa, aí depois vem medicina
funcional. Aí tempos em tempos aparecem
uns termos parecidos, né? Por exemplo, o
professor José de Felipe gosta de falar
que ele é biomolecular, que mais ou
menos é a mesma coisa que
molecular. Aí aparece outro falando que
faz medicina personalizada. Aí aparece
outro falando que faz
medicina genômica. Outro fala que faz a
medicina metabólica e por aí vai. No
final das contas é muito parecido,
tá? Eu falo que eu faço medicina
funcional, mas a medicina funcional tem
aomolecular como base. É uma medicina
que temomolecular, fitoterapia e uso
responsável de hormônios. Então, não é
só molecular, mas digamos que
automlecular é parte muito importante da
medicina que eu faço. E agora, realmente
eu não tô
acompanhando os produtores de conteúdo
que estão se identificando como medicina
metabólica, tá?
Então, eu teria dificuldade de te dizer
se eles são de boa fé ou não, porque
realmente eu não tô
acompanhando. Eh, agora a cada 3 meses
nada mais é do que uma estratégia que
muita gente usava na autoomolecular. Por
que que eu tinha um preconceito muito
grande com aomolecular há, sei lá, 15
anos atrás? Porque eu via muito colega
picareta, mas aí eu associava a
picaretagem do colega à medicina
automolecular. Eu achava que a medicina
automolecular era picaretagem, mas que
na verdade quem era picareta era o
profissional que tava usando a
ferramenta errada, aliás, usando a
ferramenta certa do jeito errado. Então
você pode ser picareta de de várias
maneiras diferentes. Você pode ser
picareta sendo um açogueiro, um
arquiteto, um engenheiro. Você pode
fazer uma medicina totalmente ortodoxa,
sendo um
urologista somente totalmente dentro do
convencional e você picareta. você pode
chegar e ficar indicando cirurgia à toa
aí, eh, e super indicando para ganhar
dinheiro. Então, eh, eu fazia essa
sensação entre oomolecular e
picaretagem, porque os profissionais que
eu conheciam eram picaretas. Então você
tem que ficar atento esse pessoal não
dessa medicina metabólica se eles não
são chegados numa empurr, né, de ficar
empurrando tratamentos necessários,
porque eu vejo um monte de colega por
aí, OK, se falando que é quântico, se se
dizendo que é medicina integrativa,
medicina não sei das quantas. Esse
pessoal, na verdade, são tratamentos em
busca de pacientes, não são pessoas que
querem realmente resolver o problema do
paciente, é a pessoa quer atrair o
paciente e encaixar esse paciente num
tratamento que ele já tem pronto lá para
ele poder cobrar esse tratamento, para
ele poder ganhar dinheiro. Aí eu sou
totalmente contra isso, tá? Então tem
que tomar muito cuidado que do mesmo
jeito que há 20 anos atrás existia e até
hoje existe, o moleculares que querem
somente arrancar dinheiro das pessoas,
existe também de várias áreas
diferentes, como eu já falei, muitos
ortodoxos fazem isso, muita gente
trabalha no Einstein, médico renomado do
Einstein, do Sírio faz isso. Então não é
uma questão de especialidade ou de área
de atuação. Então tem que ficar muito
atento ao que o colega faz. Não é
especialidade, nem o que ele diz que
faz, que vai definir, é a atitude. Então
tem que ficar muito alerta quanto a
essas coisas, tá? Cuidado. Se você
perceber que o cara tá empurrando
terapia, sai fora, corre.
Tá de nada? Bem, pessoal, acho que já tá
na hora de encerrar.
Obrigado
pela presença de vocês aqui. Eu preciso
informar uma coisa muito importante.
Semana que vem eu não tenho como fazer
live. Eu vou estar numa imersão. Eu vou
estar fora do país. Eu vou ficar duas
semanas fora. Eu vou viajar no sábado,
tá? E vou ficar duas semanas fora. A
segunda semana da viagem eu acho que eu
consigo fazer sim. Se eu tiver no lugar
de internet boa, eu não vou estar na
mais na imersão, porque eu vou ficar uma
semana na imersão e uma semana fora da
imersão, mas ainda viajando. Aí na
imersão é impossível, não vou ter
condição de fazer, mas depois da imersão
eu acho que eu consigo. Então a gente
vai ficar semana que vem sem live,
OK? Bem, muito obrigado a vocês. Nós nos
vemos então daqui a duas semanas. Um
beijo no coração. Tchau tchau. Até a
próxima.
Obrigado aí, Blanderson, pelo Boa
viagem.